in a first since the birth of this
nation the head of the Catholic Church
Pope Francis is in South Sudan together
with the Archbishop of Canterbury Justin
Walby leader the Anglican communion and
Ian greenshield the moderator of the
Scottish Church the religious leaders
are on what they call a pilgrimage for
peace in a country where fighting
continues to kill and displace large
numbers of civilians
you are called to renew the life of
society as pure sources of prosperity
and peace so greatly needed for the Sons
and Daughters of South Sudan
they need fathers not overlords they
need steady steps towards development
not constant collapses
South Sudan's leader salvikia promised
to resume talks with armed groups who
did not sign the 2018 peace deal in
honor of the Holy Father
Pope Francis
historic visit to our country
and our Declaration of 2023
as the year of peace
area consolation
I am officially announcing
the lifting of the suspension
of the room peace talks with the whole
hour groups
a day before this visit several people
were killed in central equatorial state
in violence between cattle herders and a
local militia South Sudan is a
predominantly Christian Nation in the
past the church has played a huge role
in resolving differences between
different ethnic groups and political
parties some people here hope this high
profile visit encourages their
politicians to work towards peace
the church has been urging South
Sudanese politicians not to return to
war in 2019 Pope Francis now to kiss the
feet of South Sudan's previously warring
leaders during a meeting at the Vatican
some years back the churches were
involved so much in the process that led
to the independence of South Sudan and
then on that note the church remained is
still focused on uh seeing that the
people live at peace
South Sudan broke away from Sudan to
become independent in 2011 after Decades
of conflict but long lasting peace
remains elusive people frustrated by how
long it's taking to implement the peace
agreement have huge expectations with so
many crises happening elsewhere they
hope this high profile visit reminds the
world of the needs of South Sudan Juba